you know maybe one prediction so the
audience can see this at sixty one
thousand four fourteen as of right now
uh you predicted it's gonna get to what
a hundred thousand by the end of the
year some people are saying two or three
times higher than you by the end of the
year
and you predicted 2026 bitcoin's gonna
get to a million
and the way you described it is because
an event that's going to take place in
do you mind unpacking that and
explaining what you mean
to say bitcoin is going to get to a
million by 2026.
yeah so uh it's all goes to the
programmatic monetary policy
right so when you look at bitcoin from a
structural standpoint 21 million bitcoin
will ever be created the way that that
enters into the circulating supply is
back in
2009 50 bitcoin every 10 minutes was put
into the circulating supply via
something called a bitcoin reward that
we could talk about later
uh and so that happened every 10 minutes
50 bitcoin are put into circulating
supply for four years
after four years there was a supply
shock
where that 50 bitcoin every 10 minutes
went to 25 bitcoin every 10 minutes
so it was written into code people knew
it was happening but it went
got cut in half right it's called the
bitcoin having when that event occurs
and you have a supply shock
if demand continues to grow at the same
rate you naturally will get a repricing
of an asset
right supply goes down on a daily basis
but demand stays constant or goes up
the price has to move up to accommodate
the change in the supply schedule
so 50 to 25 25 for four years and then
got cut in half again to 12 and a half
did that for four years in may of 2020
it ended up getting cut in half again
uh as it was scheduled to uh to 6.25
and so back in 2019 i said look when
this having occurs
there's going to be a repricing of the
asset right the supply
shock is going to drive the price higher
and so 100k what was the number
now the reason why i say a million
dollars by 2026
is that in 2024 there is going to be
another supply shock there will be
another cutting in half from 6.25
right 50 reduction and so naturally what
just happens
is when those supply shocks occur
there's a re-pricing by the market of
the asset
now what's really fascinating about this
if anyone studies kind of financial
markets or looks at financial assets
is that in the traditional world there's
uh commodities like let's say gold that
use stock to flow
uh analysis stock to flow simply says
how many gold how much gold is in the
world
and then how much is coming in on a
daily weekly or monthly basis and you
try to predict both the supply side of
the equation
and the demand side and therefore gives
you future price predictions
well with bitcoin you know with 100
certainty the supply side of the
schedule so i know
exactly how many bitcoin there are today
and i can tell you on each day into the
future with near 100
accuracy how many bitcoin there are
going to be so when you can model out
with accuracy the supply side and it's
programmatic
you only have to focus on predicting the
demand side
right because i know with certainty in
the in the programmatic monetary policy
supply so now it just comes down to
demand
and so what you can do is you can
basically just extrapolate out we've got
12 years of data well what's the growth
rate of people coming into bitcoin
and you just continue to extrapolate
that out and what you start to realize
is
this stock to flow analysis is deadly
accurate
right and so naturally when you see that
sure
are there days where bitcoin trades
above or below where it's supposed to be
of course right it's a volatile asset
uh in some ways but at the same time the
direction of this thing is very very
accurate because
50 of the supply demand equation is
known
and so in in this crazy crazy world
bitcoin is actually a
more predictable asset than almost any
other asset in the world
because it's fully transparent so so
at the way you described it you said
gold
is what 10 trillion you said 10 trillion
right now bitcoin is a trillion uh and
uh
the uh this is uh potentially going to
end up being twice as big as gold
uh because with gold you know you can't
really track with this it's more
trackable it's easier
so 20 trillion dollar market the 20
trillion dollar you know that breaks
down to be a million dollars
per uh bitcoin do you think it has a
possibility in 2031 to get to 5 million
do you think it has a possibility by
2040 to get to 10 million
or do you think it's going to get to a
point and kind of level off and stay
there for a while
so let's remove uh the time scale from
the conversation for a second right
to have an accurate prediction you need
to have an event and you need to have a
time
right but let's take away time for a
second and just talk about directional
progress
uh the reason why some of these
industries are so big right around
stores of value
are real estate right etc a lot of
commodity markets
is because the dollar is devalued right
if the dollar wasn't devalued if you
could simply
get paid in dollars leave it in your
bank account and have the same
or more more purchasing power in the
future you would never get out of the
dollar you would simply save right if
you go to like let's say a country like
india
uh where the culture was you basically
got gold
and then you just passed the gold dom
from generation to generation to
generation
right well in the u.s and in many
developed countries you can't do that
because the currency is being devalued
so you're financially incentivized to
either consume goods and services
or to invest the capital right and
that's part of the velocity of money and
all this kind of stuff
so that is a feature of the system not a
bug
when all of a sudden you can simply save
in an asset a currency like bitcoin you
can get paid in bitcoin and simply leave
it there
people will stop or drastically slow
down the rate of
investment into other store value assets
that's why you see gold going down and
people simply saving a bitcoin
uh you can look at uh high-end art you
can look at real estate in the future
and so in a crazy way i personally
believe
uh without a time uh prediction on it
that one day bitcoin will be a
hundred trillion dollar asset right it's
100x from here
now does that take yeah does that take
uh one year does that take 20 years 50
years i don't know right i don't want to
get into kind of the time component
because that's the hardest part of that
prediction
but what i do know is that it's not
crazy to think that if bitcoin is a
let's say 100 or 1000x improvement on
the technology front
than gold that naturally if you just are
a 10x better
or a bigger market cap than gold then
you would be 100 trillion
right because gold's 10 trillion times
10 is just 100 trillion
and so the other part of this that
becomes really crazy is
we're talking about in 2026 being 2x the
current gold market cap
right today we're sitting at a trillion
dollar bitcoin uh market cap to get to
uh 20 trillion 20x 2x the gold market
cap
well the conversation that no one's
happening is when does the flipping
happen between bitcoin and gold
it's not when bitcoin gets to 10
trillion because by the time bitcoin
continues to grow
gold's market cap is going to continue
to contract
and if you look at the actual
distribution of ownership
in gold everyone always likes to point
and say
uh oh well you use gold in your cell
phone and you know all this technology
and stuff
seven percent of gold usage or ownership
is due to any sort of technology
application the majority of it is in
store of value and jewelry jewelry
demand for b
for gold peaked in 2013 and has been on
the steady decline since
the store of value we just saw central
banks in q4 were net sellers of gold
gold's market cap is going to continue
to contract as the world gets digitized
and people literally drop gold and shift
capital into a digital store of value
and so my guess is that the kind of
flipping of gold and bitcoin's market
cap is not going to happen at the 10
trillion
maybe it's at nine or eight and a half
trillion and so you start looking at
this
very crazy world and you start saying
wait a second these are not static
numbers
right gold's market cap eventually may
be 2 trillion
just because people dump gold and they
start moving into other assets
so if you like the sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye